Algunos, increíblemente, siguen tras las pilas de combustible,
aunque no creo que dure mucho.
CA: Elon, sin embargo, ¿no tienes esa sensación
de que puedes cantar victoria y decir: "lo logramos",
deja que el mundo se electrifique, y céntrate en otras cosas?
EM: Sí.
Tengo la intención de seguir en Tesla tanto tiempo como puedo imaginar,
y hay un montón de cosas emocionantes que están por venir.
Obviamente, próximamente lanzaremos el modelo 3.
Será el camión Semi de Tesla.
CA: Bien, vamos a hablar de esto.
El modelo 3 estará disponible supuestamente en julio.
EM: Sí, creo que podremos iniciar la producción en julio.
CA: Guau.
Una de las cosas que más emociona a la gente
es el hecho de que tiene piloto automático.
Y sacaste un video hace tiempo
mostrando cómo sería esa tecnología.
EM: Sí.
Obviamente ya hay piloto automático en el modelo S.
¿Qué estamos viendo aquí?
EM: Estamos usando solo cámaras y GPS.
Aquí no se usa ni radar ni lídar.
Solamente ópticas pasivas, que son esencialmente lo que usa una persona.
Todo el sistema vial está destinado a ser navegado
con ópticas pasivas o cámaras,
una vez que resuelves las cámaras
o la visión,
se soluciona la autonomía.
Si no solucionas la visión, no se habrá solucionado.
Por eso nos enfocamos tanto en tener una visión neural
que es muy efectiva para las condiciones en carretera.
CA: Cierto. Mucha gente decide usar lídar.
Tu quieres que las cámaras y el radar hagan la mayor parte.
EM: Puedes ser un superhombre simplemente con cámaras.
Podrías ver diez veces mejor que los humanos,
solo con cámaras.
CA: Los nuevos autos a la venta tienen ocho cámaras.
Todavía no pueden hacer esto.
¿Cuándo podrán?
EM: Creo que vamos por el buen camino para poder cruzar el país
desde Los Ángeles a Nueva York a finales de año, completamente autónomo.
CA: Bien, dices que a finales de año
alguien se va a poder sentar en un Tesla sin tocar el volante,
pulsar en "Nueva York", y allá va.
EM: Sí.
CA: No tendrá que tocar el volante... para finales de 2017.
EM: Sí. Esencialmente, en noviembre o diciembre de este año,
podremos ir desde un aparcamiento en California
a un aparcamiento en Nueva York,
sin pulsar ningún mando durante todo el trayecto.
(Aplausos)
CA: Increíble.
Pero parte de esto es posible
porque ya tienes una flota de Teslas conduciendo en estas carreteras.
Estás acumulando gran cantidad de datos de la red de carreteras nacional.
EM: Sí, pero lo que será interesante
es que estoy bastante seguro de que podrá hacer esa ruta
incluso aunque cambies el recorrido de forma dinámica.
Es bastante fácil...
Si dices que va a ser muy bueno en un trayecto específico, es cierto,
pero debería poder ser realmente muy bueno,
una vez que entres en la autopista,
para ir a cualquier lugar del sistema de autopistas
de cualquier país.
No está limitado a Los Ángeles o a Nueva York.
Podemos cambiarlo y que sea de Seattle a Florida,
ese día, en tiempo real.
Así que ibas de Los Ángeles a Nueva York.
Ahora de Los Ángeles a Toronto.
CA: Dejando las normas de lado durante unos segundos,
solamente en términos tecnológicos,
para que alguien sea capaz de comprar uno de tus autos
y literalmente quitar sus manos del volante e ir a dormir,
despertarse y habrán llegado,
¿cuánto tiempo crees que falta para hacerlo de forma segura?
EM: Creo que alrededor de dos años.
El verdadero truco no es cómo hacer que funcione,
digamos, el 99,9 % del tiempo,
porque al igual que un auto colisiona una de cada mil veces,
probablemente seguirás sin estar cómodo durmiendo.
No deberías, de hecho.
(Risas)
Nunca va a ser perfecto.
Ningún sistema va a ser perfecto,
pero si dices que quizá...
es poco probable que el auto colisione
en cien vidas, o en mil vidas,
probablemente la gente diga Bien, guau, si vivo mil años
todavía será improbable que tenga una colisión,
así que quizá esté bien.
CA: Dormir.
Creo que tu mayor preocupación es que la gente pueda
engancharse demasiado pronto creyendo que es seguro,
y que ocurra un terrible incidente que deje las cosas donde estaban.
EM: Bueno, creo que el sistema autónomo debería al menos mitigar la colisión,
salvo en extrañas circunstancias.
Lo que hay que tener en cuenta para valorar la seguridad de los autos
son las probabilidades.
Quiero decir, existe la posibilidad de que un conductor humano tome el auto,
y que pueda tener un accidente, que será culpa suya.
Nunca es cero.
Realmente el umbral clave para la autonomía
es saber ¿cuánto mejor que una persona ha de ser la autonomía
antes de que puedas confiar en ella?
CA: Pero una vez que quites las manos de forma segura del volante,
la capacidad para disrumpir toda la industria parece enorme,
porque en ese punto en que hablas de gente que compre un auto,
te deje en el trabajo y lo dejas ir
y provee una especie de servicio tipo Uber a otras personas,
haciéndote ganar dinero,
quizá incluso cubrir los costes del alquiler del auto,
podrías llegar a tener un auto gratis.
¿Es realmente posible?
EM: Sí, totalmente, eso es lo que va a ocurrir.
Habrá una flota autónoma compartida
donde compres tu auto
y elijas si quieres usarlo en exclusiva,
puedes elegir compartirlo con amigos y familia,
solo con otros conductores con una valoración de 5 estrellas,
puedes compartirlo algunas veces pero otras no.
Esto es al cien por cien lo que ocurrirá.
Solo es cuestión de cuándo.
CA: Guau.
Has mencionado el Semi
y creo que planeas anunciarlo en septiembre,
pero tengo curiosidad, ¿hay algo que nos puedas mostrar hoy?
EM: Te voy a mostrar un adelanto de una fotografía del camión.
(Risas)
Está vivo.
CA: Bien.
EM: Este es un caso donde queremos ser cautelosos
con las funciones de autonomía.
Sí.
(Risas)
CA: No podemos ver mucho,
pero no parece un pequeño camión más del vecindario.
Parece un monstruo.
¿Qué tipo de semi es?
EM: Este es un semi pesado de largo recorrido.
Es el de mayor capacidad de carga
y de largo recorrido.
Esencialmente está destinado a aliviar la carga de los camiones pesados.
Y es algo que la gente no cree que hoy sea posible.
Creen que el camión no tiene la potencia o el rango necesario,
y entonces con el Tesla Semi
queremos mostrar que no, que un camión eléctrico
puede de hecho superar a cualquier semi diésel.
Si hubiese una competición de tira y afloja
el semi de Tesla remolcaría al semi diésel cuesta arriba.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
CA: Fantástico. Y a corto plazo no se conducirán solos.
Van a ser camiones que los camioneros quieran conducir.
EM: Sí. Lo que va a ser realmente divertido de esto
es que tienes una curva de par plana con un motor eléctrico
mientras que con un motor diésel u otro motor de combustión
tienes una curva de par que parece una colina.
Así que será un camión muy ágil.
Puedes conducirlo como si fuese un deportivo.
No hay marchas. Tiene una única velocidad.
CA: Hay una gran película que se hará aquí en algún lugar
no sé lo que es y no sé si acabará bien
pero es una gran película.
(Risas)
EM: Es una prueba de conducción bastante extraña.
Cuando conducía el prototipo del primer camión.
Es realmente extraño porque estás dando vueltas
y vas muy rápido, dentro de ese camión gigante.
CA: Espera, ¿ya has conducido un prototipo?
EM: Sí, lo conduje alrededor del aparcamiento,
y yo decía, esto es una locura.
CA: Guau. Esto no es vaporware.
EM: Es simplemente, conducir este camión gigante
y hacer estas maniobras disparatadas.
CA: Estupendo. De una imagen impresionante
a otra menos impresionante.
Esto es una casita adorable de "Mujeres desesperadas" o algo así.
¿Qué demonios pasa aquí?
EM: Bueno, ilustra la foto del futuro
de como creo que evolucionarán las cosas.
Tienes un auto eléctrico en la entrada.
Si miras entre el auto eléctrico y la casa
hay tres Powerwalls apiladas contra el lateral de la casa,
y luego el techo de la casa es un techo solar.
Es un techo de cristal solar.
CA: Bien.
EM: Es una foto de una casa real... bueno, en realidad es una casa falsa real.
Es una casa falsa real.
(Risas)
CA: Entonces las tejas,
algunas de ellas tienen energía solar, la capacidad de...
EM: Sí. Tejas de cristal solares
en las que puedes ajustar la textura y el color
a un nivel muy preciso,
y luego hay una especie de microlistones en el cristal,
para que cuando mires al tejado desde el nivel de la calle
o próximo al nivel de la calle,
todas las tejas parezcan iguales
tengan una celda solar detrás o no.
Hay un color uniforme
visto desde el nivel del suelo.
Si lo mirases desde un helicóptero,
podrías ver a través y distinguir
que algunas de las tejas de cristal tienen una celda solar y otras no.
Pero no se distinguen desde el suelo.
CA: Las ubicas en las más probables de ver mucho sol,
y eso hace estos tejados realmente económicos, ¿verdad?
No son mucho más caros que simplemente tejar el techo.
EM: Sí.
Estamos muy seguros de que el coste del tejado
más el coste de la electricidad...
un techo de cristales solares será más barato que un techo normal
más el coste de la electricidad.
En otras palabras,
esto económicamente será pan comido,
creemos que se verá bien,
y que durará...
Pensamos en hacer una garantía de por vida,
pero entonces la gente pensó
que podría parecer que no hablábamos en serio,
pero es realmente vidrio templado.
Después de que la casa se haya desplomado
y no quede nada allí,
las tejas de cristal seguirán ahí.
(Aplausos)
CA: Es increíble.
Creo que vas a sacar todo esto en un par de semanas
con cuatro tipos de techo diferentes.
EM: Sí, inicialmente vamos a empezar con dos,
y los próximos dos los presentaremos a principios del próximo año.
CA: ¿Y cuál es la escala de ambición?
¿Cuántas casas crees que podrían acabar teniendo ese tejado?
EM: Creo que, con el tiempo
casi todas las casas tendrán techo solar.
Lo que hay que considerar es la escala de tiempo
que será probablemente alrededor
de 40 o 50 años.
De media, un tejado se reemplaza cada 20 o 25 años.
Aunque no empiezas a cambiar todas las tejas de inmediato.
Pero a la larga, si avanzásemos rápidamente
hasta dentro de 15 años,
no será habitual tener un tejado que no sea solar.
Hay algún modelo mental que se le escapa a la gente,
porque el cambio en el coste, el ahorro con la energía solar,
la mayoría de las casas tienen la suficiente luz solar en sus techos
como para cubrir todas sus necesidades.
Si pudiesen capturar la energía,
podrían cubrir todas sus necesidades.
Casi podrían desconectarse de la red.
EM: Depende dónde estés
qué tipo de casa sea, con respecto al área del tejado
pero es justo decir
que la mayoría de casas en EE.UU. tienen suficiente área de tejado
como para cubrir sus necesidades energéticas.
CA: Entonces el aspecto clave para economizar
los autos, el semi, las casas
es la caída del precio de las baterías de ion de litio,
con las que has apostado fuerte en Tesla.
En muchos sentidos, es la principal competencia.
Y has decidido
que para realmente ser dueño de esa competencia,
tenías que construir la planta de fabricación más grande del mundo
para doblar el suministro mundial de baterías de ion de litio,
con este tipo. ¿Qué es esto?
EM: Lo llamamos la gigafábrica,
el progreso hasta ahora en la gigafábrica.
Quizás puedas llegar a ver
que tiene una especie de forma de diamante
y cuando este acabada se verá como un diamante gigante,
o esa es la idea tras ello,
y está alineado al norte verdadero.
Es un pequeño detalle.
CA: Será capaz de producir, con el tiempo,
como cien gigavatios/hora de baterías cada año.
EM: cien gigavatios/hora. Creemos que será algo más.
CA: Y ya se está produciendo en estos momentos.
EM: Ya está en producción. CA: Lo han mostrado en este video.
Me pregunto.. ¿lo han acelerado?
EM: Es la versión ralentizada.
(Risas)
CA: ¿Cuán rápido va?
EM: Bueno, cuando va a máxima velocidad
no se pueden ver las celdas sin ver una luz estroboscópica.
Está todo borroso.
(Risas)
CA: Una de tus ideas centrales, Elon, sobre cómo será un futuro emocionante
es un futuro en que ya no nos sentiremos culpables por la energía.
Ayúdanos a imaginarlo.
¿Cuántas gigafábricas, si te parece, nos harán falta para llegar a eso?
EM: Unas cien, más o menos.
No son diez, no son mil.
Probablemente cien.
CA: Es asombroso.
Puedes imaginarte lo que haría falta
para alejar al mundo de los combustibles fósiles.
Es como si estuvieses construyendo uno,
cuesta USD 5000 millones,
o entre cinco y diez mil millones de dólares.
Es fantástico que puedas imaginar este proyecto.
Y en Tesla planeas... anunciar otras dos este año.
EM: Creo que anunciaremos ubicaciones
de unas dos o cuatro gigafábricas a lo largo del año.
Sí, probablemente cuatro.
CA: Guau.
(Aplausos)
¿No te tienta decirnos más?
como... ¿en qué continente?
Puedes decir que no.
EM: Necesitamos enfrentar un mercado global.
CA: Bien.
(Risas)
Fenomenal.
Creo que deberíamos hablar...
de hecho, táchalo.
Te voy a hacer una pregunta sobre política, solo una.
Estoy bastante harto de la política pero te quiero preguntar.
Estás en un organismo ahora asesorando a un tipo...
EM: ¿Quién?
CA: que dijo que no cree en el cambio climático,
y hay muchas personas que piensan que no deberías hacerlo.
Les gustaría que te alejases de eso.
¿Qué les dirías?
EM: Bueno, ante todo,
solamente estoy en dos consejos asesores
cuyo formato consiste en dar vueltas en la sala
y preguntar la opinión de la gente en ciertos asuntos,
hay una reunión cada mes o cada dos meses.
Ese es el monto total de mi contribución.
Pero piensa hasta qué punto hay gente en esa sala
que está discutiendo a favor de hacer algo con el cambio climático,
o problemas sociales.
He usado las reuniones que tenido hasta ahora
para debatir a favor de la inmigración y a favor del cambio climático.
(Aplausos)
Y si no hubiese hecho eso,
no hubiese estado en la agenda.
Así que probablemente no pase nada, pero por lo menos se ha hablado.
CA: Bien.
(Aplausos)
Hablemos de SpaceX y Marte.
La última vez que viniste,
hablaste sobre lo que parecía ser un sueño increíblemente ambicioso
para desarrollar cohetes reutilizables.
Y ha sido irte y hacerlo.
EM: Por fin. Llevó mucho tiempo.
CA: Háblanos sobre esto. ¿Qué estamos viendo?
EM: Este es uno de los cohetes aceleradores
volviendo a gran velocidad de una gran altitud en el espacio.
Acaba de entregar la etapa superior
a alta velocidad.
Creo que todo esto se ha hecho a mach 7,
la entrega de la etapa superior.
(Aplausos)
CA: Fue una versión acelerada...
EM: Era la versión ralentizada.
(Risas)
CA: Pensaba que era la versión acelerada.
Pero es increíble,
y muchos han fallado
antes de que finalmente encontraran el modo de hacerlo,
pero ahora ya lo han hecho ¿cuántas veces? ¿cinco o seis?
EM: Unas ocho o nueve.
CA: Y por primera vez,
has hecho volver a volar uno de los cohetes que aterrizaron.
EM: Sí, aterrizamos el acelerador del cohete
lo preparamos para volar de nuevo y voló otra vez,
es el primer vuelo de un acelerador reciclado.
por eso es relevante.
Es importante apreciar que la reusabilidad solo es relevante
si es rápida y completa.
Como un avión o un auto,
la reusabilidad es rápida y completa.
No envías un avión a Boeing entre un vuelo y otro.
CA: Cierto. Esto te permite entonces soñar con esta ambiciosa idea
de enviar mucha, mucha, gente a Marte
en, ¿cuánto? 10 o 20 años, ¿no?
EM: Sí.
CA: Y has diseñado este monstruoso cohete para ello.
Ayúdanos a entender la escala de esta cosa.
EM: Bueno, visualmente pueden ver que eso es una persona
Y esto es el vehículo.
(Risas)
CA: Así que si fuese un rascacielos,
he leído que sería ¿cómo un rascacielos de 40 plantas?
EM: Probablemente un poco más.
La capacidad de propulsión es realmente...
su configuración es cuatro veces la propulsión del cohete Saturno V.
CA: Cuatro veces la propulsión del mayor cohete que la humanidad ha creado nunca.
EM: Sí, sí.
CA: Cosas que uno hace. EM: Sí.
(Risas)
Midiéndolo en 747, que tiene una propulsión de 1/4 de millón de libras,
cada 10 millones de libras de propulsión,
tenemos 40 Boeing 747.
Sería el equivalente en propulsión a 120 747 con todos sus motores en marcha.
CA: Y eso con una máquina diseñada para escapar de la gravedad terrestre,
creo que la última vez dijiste
que esta cosa podía llevar un 747 completamente cargado,
tripulación, carga, todo,
en órbita.
EM: Exacto. Puede llevar un 747 totalmente cargado,
máximo combustible, lleno de pasajeros y máxima carga...
como carga.
CA: Basándose en esto,
has presentado recientemente un Sistema de Transporte Interplanetario
que se visualiza de este modo.
Esta es una escena que te imaginas ¿en cuánto? ¿veinte, treinta años?
Gente entrando en este cohete.
EM: Soy optimista en que será en un marco de 8 a 10 años.
Ambiciosamente, ese es nuestro objetivo.
Nuestro objetivo interno es más agresivo, pero creo...
(Risas)
CA: Bien.
EM: Dado que el vehículo parece un poco grande
y es grande si lo comparas con otros cohetes,
creo que la nave espacial del futuro
hará que esto parezca un bote de remos.
Las naves espaciales del futuro serán realmente enormes.
CA: ¿Por qué, Elon?
¿Por qué necesitamos construir una ciudad en Marte
con un millón de personas y que vivas para verlo,
que creo que es más o menos lo que has dicho que te encantaría?
EM: Es importante tener
un futuro inspirador y atractivo.
Creo que tiene que haber razones
para que te levantes por la mañana y quieras vivir.
Porque, ¿por qué quieres vivir?
¿Cuál es el sentido? ¿Qué te inspira?
¿Qué te apasiona acerca del futuro?
Y si no estamos ahí fuera,
si el futuro no incluye estar ahí fuera entre las estrellas
y ser una especie multiplanetaria,
me parecería realmente deprimente
que ese no sea el futuro que vamos a tener.
(Aplausos)
CA: A la gente le gustaría posicionarse
hay mucha desesperación actualmente en el planeta
desde el clima hasta la pobreza, o cualquier otro problema.
Y esto parece una distracción.
No deberías pensar en esto.
Deberías resolver lo que ocurre aquí y ahora.
Y para ser justo, ya has hecho bastante
con tu trabajo en la energía sostenible.
Pero, ¿por qué no hacer eso?
EM: Creo que hay...
Miro al futuro desde el punto de vista de las probabilidades.
Es como un torrente de ramificaciones de probabilidades,
y hay acciones que podemos hacer que afectan estas probabilidades
aceleran unas o ralentizan otras.
Podría introducir algo nuevo al torrente probabilístico.
Las energías sostenibles son ya un hecho.
Si no hubiese Tesla, si Tesla no existiese,
habría surgido necesariamente.
Es redundante.
Si no tienes energía sostenible, quiere decir que no es sostenible.
A la larga te quedarás sin ella,
y las leyes de la economía llevarán a la civilización
hacia las energías sostenibles,
inevitablemente.
El valor fundamental de una compañía como Tesla
es el grado en el que acelera el advenimiento de la energía sostenible,
más rápido de lo que hubiese ocurrido.
Cuando pensamos
cuál es el principal sentido de una compañía como Tesla,
yo diría, siendo optimista,
que si se adelanta una década, potencialmente más de una década,
será un gran hecho.
Por eso lo considero
el aspecto fundamental al que aspira Tesla.
Después está el convertirse en una especie multiplanetaria.
No es inevitable.
Es muy importante valorar que no es inevitable.
La energía sostenible del futuro es esencialmente inevitable,
pero ser una civilización espacial no es inevitable.
Si te fijas en el progreso espacial,
en 1969 fuimos capaces de enviar a alguien a la luna.
1969.
Después tuvimos el transbordador espacial.
El transbordador espacial solo podía llevar gente a la órbita baja terrestre.
Luego retiramos al transbordador espacial,
y EE.UU. no podía poner a nadie en órbita.
Esa es la tendencia.
La tendencia es no hacer nada.
La gente se confunde cuando piensa
que la tecnología mejora de forma automática.
No mejora de forma automática.
Solo mejora si muchas personas trabajan arduamente para que mejore,
y de hecho creo que se degrada por sí misma.
Si miras a las grandes civilizaciones como el Antiguo Egipto,
ellos fueron capaces de hacer las pirámides,
y olvidaron como hacerlo.
Y los romanos construyeron esos increíbles acueductos.
Olvidaron como hacerlo.
CA: Elon, casi parece al escucharte
y ver las distintas cosas que has hecho,
que tienes esa extraordinaria doble motivación para todo
que me parece muy interesante.
Una es el deseo de trabajar para el bien a largo plazo de la humanidad.
La otra es el deseo de hacer algo emocionante.
Y a menudo parece que sientes como si una cosa llevase a la otra.
Con Tesla quieres tener energía sostenible,
así que haces estos autos realmente atractivos para ello.
Energía solar, tenemos que hacerlo,
así que hagamos estos preciosos tejados.
Ni siquiera hemos hablado sobre lo último que has hecho,
para lo que no tenemos tiempo,
pero quieres salvar a la humanidad de las malas inteligencias artificiales,
así que vas a crear esta increíble interfaz cerebro-máquina
para darnos a todos memoria infinita, telepatía, etcétera.
Y en Marte, parece que lo que nos dices es,
sí, tenemos que salvar a la humanidad
y tener un plan B,
pero también tenemos que inspirar a la humanidad
y esta es una forma de inspirar.
EM: Creo que el valor de la belleza y la inspiración
está muy infravalorado,
sin lugar a dudas.
Pero quiero ser claro.
No intento ser el salvador de nadie.
Esa no es...
solo intento pensar en el futuro
y no entristecerme.
(Aplausos)
CA: Bonita declaración.
Creo que todos estarán de acuerdo
en que esto no es...
Nada de esto va a pasar de forma inevitable.
El hecho de que en tu mente sueñes estas cosas,
sueñas cosas que nadie más se atrevería a soñar,
o nadie más sería capaz de soñar
con ese nivel de complejidad.
El hecho de que hagas eso, Elon Musk, es realmente extraordinario.
Gracias por ayudarnos a soñar un poco más a lo grande.
EM: Pero me dirás si alguna vez empieza a ser una verdadera locura, ¿no?
(Risas)
CA: Gracias, Elon Musk. Fue realmente fantástico.
Realmente fantástico.
(Aplausos)